immaginate che arrivi qualcuno e dice
ted cambiamo acronimo non è technology
entertainment design ma è qualcos'altro
voi come reagireste perché pensate come
devono aver reagito
il consiglio di amministrazione della bp
si chiamava british petrolium e con la
pressione della cittadinanza della
stampa scelsero un altro nome
beyond petroleum quindi oltre il
petrolio perché parto da qui perché ieri
l'associazione dei petrolieri italiani
ha cambiato nome si chiamerà
associazione per le energie per la
mobilità chiacchiere o realtà
questo è esattamente il punto in cui
siamo chiacchiere o realtà
ed è il punto in cui questa crisi ci
obbliga a un'accelerazione delle
decisioni perché abbiamo capito tutti
che non c'è più tempo
la scienza ci dice che c'è una
correlazione tra inquinamento e gravità
del copit non una causa azione ancora ma
nella testa della gente
il click è scappato e vediamo quante
persone hanno cambiato improvvisamente
modo di spostarsi
questo è una cosa da da fighetti è una
parola si può usare o è un cambiamento
strutturale
io trovo che in italia sia fatta una
polemica incredibile su gli incentivi
alla mobilità cosiddetta dolce e cioè
biciclette a pedalata assistita
monopattini eccetera
quando ci sono 19 miliardi all'anno
di sussidi che vanno invece a
danneggiare l'ambiente
eppure nessuno ha detto ma che state
dicendo la battuta che facevamo durante
il lock down che era proprio il momento
di tagliarli perché se anche i tir
avessero fatto avessero bloccato le
città non c'è nessuno in giro a
imprecare la sto mettendo un po così in
senso di gioco ma non è un gioco perché
non è un gioco perché l'europa adesso
con questi famosi fondi di un fondo che
si chiama next generation you non
recovery fund io ogni volta solo
intervistato massacro chi usa questo
termine perché vi ricordate quando anni
fa c'era una attrice che faceva la presa
in giro della ministra della pubblica
istruzione che non riusciva di
repubblica infatti fu cambiato anche il
nome del ministero e si chiama
dell'istruzione
ecco noi next generation new york
proprio non ce la facciamo perché perché
vogliamo usare questi soldi per
guadagnare magari qualche decimo di pil
nel famoso rimbalzo che speriamo tutti
ci siano anno prossimo ma l'europa ci
dice momento il 37 per cento di quei
soldi deve andare alla lotta contro la
crisi climatica giusto quello che stavo
detto prima non cambiamento climatico la
crisi climatica e poi il 20 per cento
alla digitalizzazione e poi e poi ecco
37 miliardi
e se il 37 per cento vuol dire 77
miliardi ma poi l'europa dice adesso ci
dovete dire come li volete usare e come
li coordinate con i fondi nazionali qui
19 miliardi
immaginate che l'italia non faccia nulla
credo che gli altri paesi europei
soprattutto i paesi frugali
direbbero scusate intanto usate i vostri
soldi poi tutta più i nostri
ecco dove siamo e l'europa da questo
punto di vista va elogiata e lodata per
che ha tenuto la barra dritta nonostante
la crisi
nell'evento di presentazione del
rapporto asbis dell'altro giorno il
commissario europeo agli affari
economici paolo gentiloni ha detto
guardate che da noi sono venuti a dirci
dateci le mani libere facciamo il
rimbalzo economico come abbiamo sempre
fatto e noi gli abbiamo detto di no
abbiamo detto che il green new deal
serve all'ambiente ma serve anche
all'economia e sapete cosa hanno fatto
hanno deciso che i 100 miliardi che
servono per le missioni che servono per
pagare il fondo shore cioè la cassa
integrazione le indennità di
disoccupazione
verranno raccolti con social bond cioè
con dei titoli che vanno a impattare
direttamente con degli indicatori chiari
sugli aspetti sociali e il 30 per cento
dei famosi e 750 miliardi del next
generation saranno green bond cioè
titoli che vanno esattamente in quella
direzione
lo dico a te arrivo la conclusione
perché si poteva fare anche prima
bene che si faccia adesso per dire che
dipende da noi dipende da noi
naturalmente nelle micro decisioni come
abbiamo sentito ma dipende da noi dalla
politica in questo momento ecco la
differenza tra una resilienza cioè la
capacità di tornare indietro dopo una
crisi e la residenza trasformativa cioè
rimbalzo in avanti non a caso il fondo
europeo si chiama per la ripresa e la
resilienza e ogni volta che noi
dimentichiamo questo nome come per il
next generation
pensiamo che tutto sommato possiamo
tornare un anno fa e invece no